[Music]
[Applause]
who is it bonzai Daniel Larusso here for
Larusso Auto we are chopping prices on
all of our inventory yeah
Johnny I knew it was you
this is Johnny Lawrence he and I go way
back oh this a guy who's a she Kate if
you want to get technical I kicked his
face hey watch your car man
[Applause]
was I like Taekwondo over something
that's karate do you think you could
teach me I'm driving home from work
yesterday and in this strip mall
I see after 30 years I thought that guy
might have changed that it's still the
same print
I heard you beat up a bunch of teenagers
they didn't beat up any teenagers I
kicked the crap out of a bunch of
[__] who deserved it thinks he could
bring Cobra Kai back to the valley yeah
not on my watch
you know what those kids at school -
keep dumping things on your head you own
all the girls to think you're a Wang
less door you're doing that karate
teacher no I'm gonna be your sensei
[Applause]
I'm gonna teach you the style of karate
that was taught to me a method of
fighting your pansy-ass generation
desperately needs okay let's see what
you got
she's a girl and I'm sorry are you okay
I was a natural Cobra
[Music]
chime you and I miss we were done
you